this is a production of Cornell
University
so my name is Julia Frieza I teach
several classes at Cornell aiming to
integrate many field of science
including plant biochemistry ethnobotany
traditional medicine pharmacology and
Drug Discovery in the classical
curriculum focusing on evidence-based
approach to Medicinal plant species
here I plotted in more clouds the
student population enrolling my courses
at corner University and the course I
teach online to demonstrate the large
academic diversity of students in my
classes
and also to demonstrate the strong
interest from University students of all
disciplines to learn about medicinal and
pharmacological property or plant
compounds
the majority of my students are pre-med
many from cows like plant biology major
environmental and sustainability major
from human ecology student interest in
global Health but also students from the
Dyson School of Business biomedical and
biological engineering
my students also include Cornell alumni
Healthcare professional nurse
practitioner and medical doctors
in the last seven years I developed and
I'm currently teaching several classes
covering the pharmaceutical property of
plant compounds there is an obvious uh
obviously a great appeal for this topic
my undergraduate master classes always
reach full enrollment with long waiting
lists and equal now certificate that
developed is one of the most popular is
certificate within cows
synchronous courses that I teach are
plan bio2100 this is also called medical
ethnobotany it's a course that explore
the relationship between plants people
and culture
according to the World Health
Organization eighty percent of the world
population in developing countries
depend on traditional and herbal
medicine for the treatment of diseases
so in this sense ethnobotany is really
the science of survival
um particularly popular class this one
because students can relate to their own
personal experience with Plan B medicine
and verify maybe popular claims through
the scientific literature
students get familiar with the past and
current plant-based natural remedies
used across the globe exploring their
efficacy and mode of action
when we study natural compounds we
observe that there are medicinal values
is often due to a synergistic action of
multiple components and that's not
really always fit our modern concept of
drug discovery which rely on the
isolation and study of single compound
drugs
the course emphasize the importance of
preservation of indigenous knowledge
native culture and languages and
distinguish between bioprospecting and
biopiracy and discuss intellectual
property with many examples
plan bios 3 100 is a higher level course
exploring the biochemical and
pharmacological property of isolated
bioactive compounds farming plants a
source of medicine sold by
pharmaceutical companies the course
cover the distribution of plant
secondary metabolites the use of
technique in the isolation and structure
illustration of natural products the
physical chemical characteristic
pharmacokinetic property and the steps
involving drug production and Drug
approval in the western medicine
it explores synthetic and semi-synthetic
analog study for different reasons
including finding new patentable
isolated compound pharmaceutical scalar
production guarantee a sustainable
Source tweak natural product structure
to decrease toxicity and or to increase
by your bioviability
plant science 5045 cannabis chemistry
and pharmacology including bioviability
and mode of action toxicology and safety
of cannabis by Electric compound it's
another very popular class among Master
students and undergraduates
and this course cover the function of
the endocannabinoid system in the human
body the biosynthesis and distribution
of plant terpenoids and cannabinoids
the technique used in the isolation and
structural elucidation the value of
biological essay and the step involving
drug production and approval
um I also teach some classes to Cornell
alumni that have been very very popular
with close to 100
participants and really long waiting
lists the classes discuss plant-based
natural remedies used across Melania and
across the globe considering their
efficacy mode of action and effect on
our body while expanding our
understanding of the natural world
traditional medicine
and human diversity
I also created various courses that
asynchronously including Equinox
certificate formed by six courses on
medicinal plants opens to students
worldwide
Econo certificate the certificate
examine the historical application a
plant-based medicine the compounds that
are commonly found the potential safety
consideration and how to critically
evaluate labels and packaging of
plant-based medicine
I am currently developing a new Equinox
certificate on medical cannabis
this is a five course certificate which
contextualized the role of cannabis
through history medicine and the legal
system
analyze the most popular extraction
method and how this affect the chemical
profiling of the plant and the medical
cannabis product
it analyzed the difference synergies
between chemical compounds composition
in the cannabis plants and understand
the pharmacology
of cannabis bioactive compounds how
medicinal cannabis products get to the
market
via the FDA approval
it also explore how medical and
recreational Cannabis differ and what
type of products are currently available
in medical dispensaries
um I also have been a visiting professor
at the department of pharmaceutical
science at the University of Padua in
Italy winner of a shaping a world-class
University Grant and I taught plant
um as green Factory for pharmaceutical
from medicinal botany to large scale
production
to this was a class for pharmacology
Master student we also reached full
enrollment and was very well received
so my main goal as a teacher is really
to share with my students the world of
Wonders and complexity of plant
chemistry exploring their potential for
solution to health dietary and
sustainable issue in a
multi-disciplinary approach transferring
this enthusiasm for the natural world
I discussed
many different traditional medicine
systems here you can see that many of
the medical Traditions that we consider
to be part of the past
actually really persist today worldwide
as part of traditional medicine and
Indigenous culture such as ayurveda
Campo Jammu Shamanism and corianderism
practice in Central South America Native
American traditional medicine in North
America and Canada and so on and the
point here is that natural medicine can
be found in every region of the world
today
um topics these are some of the topics
and structure of my courses with which
always emphasize case study with many
examples
and over the past year I implemented
teaching programs of active learning
to increase student retention and
satisfaction and engage my students in
route Outreach activities with Community
outside the university
including the Cayuga nation and
currently with Harlem grow
um in conclusion these are some of the
topics discussing my courses
and finally I would like to conclude
with a few questions for a reflection
in 2010 Dr Margaret Chan director
general of the World Health Organization
Advocates the two system of traditional
medicine and Western medicine need not
to clash quote they can blend together
in a beneficial Harmony using the best
feature of each system and compensating
process for certain weaknesses of each
now in some part of the word such as
Japan and China most medical doctors are
trained in both herbal traditional
medicine and Western medicine and apply
them daily to their patients depending
on the severity and condition of the
patient illnesses
now I would like you to reflect on this
question what is the role of natural
products in modern medicine in the
modern medicine system
is the endocannabinoid system and
medical cannabis studied and covered in
the medical curriculum why and why not
how can we integrate traditional
medicine and Western medicine for the
benefit of all
how can we educate students and patients
to the risk and benefits of plant-based
medicine
finally I would like to conclude with my
favorite quotes the rainforest old
answer to question we have yet to ask
and this is because humans have been
turned into nature for solution to
health and healing for millennia
but as we know environments are imperial
ecosystem are understood
and when we lose a plant species with
that we lose millions of years of
evolution and a natural chemical Factory
so sustainable future involves not just
respect and preservation of the
diversity of the natural world and
Native people and Native culture but
also education play a crucial role in it
and that's why we're here
so thank you all and I hope to meet you
also
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu